[Music]
rachel article came out in inc magazine
today southwest air just made a tough
decision is it risky or smart
southwest is trying to do one thing
harvard business school they say
to do the opposite well i think i know
whose side i'm going to come down on
this already
i'm just guessing that southwest air
might know more about business in their
little finger than harvard business
school does in the whole freaking campus
but i could be wrong
let's look and see what the article says
both united airlines american airlines
warned over the summer they would start
furloughing thousands of workers on
october 1st if that date passed
without an extension of the federal aid
to airlines that the government approved
in april the october 1st deadline passed
the stimulus didn't
but at southwest which lost 17 million
dollars a day
oh my gosh during the third quarter 17
million
a day has seen revenue drop 70 percent
ceo gary kelly did something a bit
different now
sidebar it's fair to note because i'm
biased rachel's biased
we know we know mr gary kelly and
you know him i don't well you've been
you've met him here and i know him
fairly well and he's spoken for us at
andre leadership
and he is an incredible man wonderful
he's an incredible leader
and a person of character so i will go
ahead and say that i know that up front
and that would taint
my reading of this article this week
kelly recorded a video
for employees in which he said southwest
will keep its streak
of not having had layoffs or furloughs
for its entire history
at least until the end of the year while
kelly would of course welcome
federal aid he said he's no longer
counting on the government
instead he wants southwest to cut its
own corners he's starting with himself
he will go without a salary until the
end of the year oh until the end of 2021
for a year and a half yeah the other
senior executives will take a 20
pay cut during that same period of time
other non-union employees will take a
pay cut of 10 percent
so that everybody can keep their jobs
kelly promised there would be no layoffs
through the end of 2021
and their salaries will snap back regain
the 10
pay cut after one year
he said he'll also be asking unions to
match the pay cuts
my goal has been and it remains no
furloughs no layoffs
if we fail to reach an agreement on
reasonable concessions with the unions
quickly
that will be the last resort basically
putting the
ball in the union's court both of the
unions representing southwest air flight
attendants poured out coal
poured cold water on the idea of
voluntary cuts flight attendants union
sent me a statement saying they had made
it clear that the company in previous
conversations that our members are not
interested in making concessions to a
contract
that took decades to obtain
agreeing to discussions is different to
agreeing to concession
so we put the unions in the corner and
they're coming out looking like
fools because if you're if you're a
union guy and you don't understand that
that when money's not there it doesn't
matter what your contract says
i can help you with that they're going
to lay your butt off
you're gone okay
union contracts do not create money
where there's not money
and when the entire top echelon of
leadership takes a pay cut and down
and no pay and everybody else takes a
pay cut
but you stand there with your little lip
stuck out it leaves you guys looking
stupid in this union i'll just tell you
i mean you union people be mad at me if
you want to be mad at me but this is
this is a basic math problem a company
trying to survive trying to help
everybody keep their jobs
and the unions being a grouch there's a
different the unions are you know if the
company's being greedy yeah get after
them
this is not about greed it's about
freaking survival you doobs
it seems pay cuts might be best but it
happens to fly
in the face of the advice that harvard
business school professor
christopher stanton and some of his
colleagues give they say lay people off
instead of cutting salaries otherwise
you risk your top performers moving on
and you risk morale
they don't take into consideration that
morale is not a problem
at southwest air oh i was going to say
morale i i you almost
i mean if i'm working for a company and
the ceo
and the top execs are cutting their
salary that makes
me taking no pay and he takes no pay
that makes me almost more loyal to them
where i'm like you're sacrificing your
life to keep me
thank you i mean what you would think it
would yes but i'm like
it would i so it's just funny that the
harvard guys are like oh no that's going
to like
hurt yeah because see they think morale
is based on uh money and it's not it's
based on culture
and one of the strongest culture
companies in america is southwest
yeah yep um and uh the culture there is
you can cut it with a knife it's so
thick hey i would travel i traveled
all the time on commercial for so long
southwest
i ended up that's the only place i would
fly because they were the easiest
if stuff happened oh they were so
accommodating they're wonderful
wonderful compared to other airlines so
yeah i'm a southwest we're big fans
they're not advertisers were they didn't
pay us to be sponsors or something like
that but
i will southwest if you want to give me
some if you want to come up if you want
to come on the radio and be an
advertiser while you're broke that'd be
great but yeah
i don't think this is happening rachel i
know it's going to help you with that
they just cut pay okay i know i know i
know i'm putting two and two together
uh so uh this is all about saving jobs
gary laid out a plan the article says
to do just that save the jobs our
business is in intensive care and our
ceo is doing everything possible to save
jobs and navigate through it
now we pick on all of us in america pick
on politicians and we pick on
corporate greed people but when they
behave
in manners that is not greedy when they
behave in a manner with character we
also need to call them out and say
well done well done because i don't know
when i've seen
in an organization that size the
leadership team step up and say
we're not going to get paid so you can
just keep your job
we're going to survive it's amazing and
now they make a lot more money and
they've got some money in the bank and
they're probably i don't know
i suspect gary's a millionaire
multi-millionaire probably as he should
be
he's the freaking ceo of southwest i
mean really but uh um
you know i he in other words he's
probably okay at home he's probably not
gonna lose his house because of this or
something
i suspect that would be shocking to me
so it's not like that but but they did
you know leaders real leaders
put the team that they lead the good of
the team ahead of themselves
otherwise you shouldn't have a team uh
you know if your team's not worthy
of you being sacrificial to keep them in
place you shouldn't have had them there
anyway
you should have already fired them
because they're not worthy
and so this is the way we did it at
ramsey but we're a little 900 person
organization we're not
17 million dollars a day burn rate
goodness it's hard to get your mind
around
but you know there are some people out
there in the middle of this covet
suppression nightmare
ridiculous mess that we're in the middle
of economically
that was contrived as crud
but the airlines are just they're their
finances are a disaster
and here's a guy standing with his face
in the fire
doing the right thing hats off to you my
friend gary
hats off to you southwest we love you we
hope you guys make it we hope you turn
it around
and prove one more time that what we
already knew that harvard business
school is not worth the money